[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition 100 % Sénat pour suivre
aujourd'hui le vote d'une proposition de
loi c'était mercredi en séance ici à la
Haute Assemblée les sénateurs qui ont
adopté une loi de réhabilitation des
personnes condamnées pour homosexualité
dans la période 1945- 1982 en effet le
régime de Vichy a mis en place une
législation une loi de haine a même dit
Éric dupontmeretti pendant les échanges
au Sénat qui venait discriminer
particulièrement les homosexuels ainsi
pendant 40 ans des hommes ont été
condamnés et parfois lourdement
sanctionnés pour leur orientation
sexuelle une sénatrice a ainsi parlé de
ce brillant avocat du Nord qui avait
réussi le concours du barreau et bien du
fait de sa condamnation il a fini sa vie
comme surveillant dans un internat d'un
lycée et des révocations de la fonction
publique ont aussi été prononcé de même
que des licenciements le texte venu de
la gauche sénatoriale reconnaît donc ces
discriminations mais ne met pas en place
de système de réparation ce serait trop
compliqué à mettre en œuvre a dit la
droite sénatoriale enfin à noter cette
proposition de loi doit encore être
adopté par l'Assemblée nationale pour
terminer son parcours législatif c'est
ce débat que nous allons suivre dans
l'hémicycle ça se tenait mercredi au
Sénat j'ai l'honneur de vous proposer
cette proposition de loi de la soumettre
à vosb et à vos votes cette proposition
de loi dont je suis l'auteur et qui vise
à la reconnaissance et à la réparation
des personnes condamnées pour
homosexualité en France entre 1942 et
1982 je tiens à remercier les 102
collègues sénateurs et sénatristes qui
ont Cigné cette proposition de loi je
tiens à saluer les collègues qui ont été
élus à la fin du mois de septembre qui
ont manifester leur soutien à cette
initiative
parlementaire la diversité politique des
CIN ataire démontre une
chose nous traitons dans un climat
apaisé d'un sujet qui peut faire et qui
doit faire
consensus cette proposition de loi est
animée par quelques idées simples la
quête de la vérité et la recherche de la
justice ce sont ces valeurs qui m'ont
servi de boussole dans le cheminement m
on conduit à la rédaction et au dépôt de
ce
texte les lois mémorieles se donnent
bien souvent pour mission de réconcilier
un pays avec son histoire en effet
l'histoire de chaque pays est faite de
part de lumière dont il convient de
tirer une légitime fierté et de part
d'ombre dont on gagne à reconnaître la
véracité l'histoire de France l'histoire
de notre pays n'échappe pas à cette
règle il s'appelait Henri de monterl
Roger pfit Michel chomara Bernard
bousset ils étaient célèbres et surtout
anonymes ils aimaient la France il l'a
servé il l'a célébré il s'était engagé
pour certains d'entre eux dans la
résistance comme Gan déborde il
chantaiit la France comme Charles traîné
mais avec eux comme avec des dizaines de
milliers d'hommes et des centaines de
femmes la France ne fut pas douce elle
fut au contraire cruelle la France a
dépénalisé l'homosexualité en 1791 dans
le code napoléonien au lendemain de la
Révolution française devenant un des
pays les plus progressist en la matière
nous le devons au juriste montpellérin
jean-jacqu régist de cambaser hélas sous
la 3è République de grand commis de
l'État pressé le gouvernement de sévir
contre
l'homosexualité si la France a
dépénalisé l'homosexualité en
1781 devenant donc ces pays
progressistes cette parenthèse libérale
fut de courte durée quelques années plus
tard ces grands commis de l'État vurent
leurs vœux exaucés par le maréchal Pétin
en août 42
l'ère du temps n'expliquera jamais ce
retour en arrière en effet à la même
période en Europe la Suède la Suisse ou
encore la Pologne décriminaliser les
relations entre personnes de même sexe à
rebours de son histoire la France
instauré une majorité sexuelle de 21 ans
pour les homosexuels contre 13 ans pour
les hétérosexuels une discriminance
discrimination d'apparence anodine mais
qui légitimera jusqu'à la fin de la
guerre la
persécution ation et la condamnation de
dizaines de milliers d'hommes dans notre
pays quelques centaines d'entre eux
furent hélas déportés depuis la France
vers les camps de rééducation et de
concentration longemps éclipsé de la
mémoire collective ce ce qui était
obligé de porter le triangle rose ont
été progressivement réhabilités nous le
devons aux travaux des historiens
auxquels je veux rendre un hommage
Florence stamagne régisten Michel
Bertrand à la Libération alors que la
plupart des lois de Pétin sont projet le
ministre de la Justice de l'époque
François deonton fait le choix de
conserver cette loi qui réprimait
l'homosexualité tout en la défendant et
en la justifiant dans son ordonnance du
8 Mai
45 outre cette disposition la
législation prohibant les relations
homosexuelles se renforcera en 1960 par
l'adoption de l'amendement de député
Paul mirget député de la Moselle qui
créera l'alinéa 2 de l'article 330 du
code pénal en effet en 1960 Paul merg
considérait que l'homosexualité était un
fléau social qu'il convenait de
combattre il réussit à convaincre une
majorité de députés de doubler la peine
pour outrage à la pudeur lorsqu'il
s'agissait de rapport homosexuel créant
de fait une circonstance aggravante
cette nouvelle législation répressive
entraînera une persécution
disproportionnée des personnes
homosexuelles traquées dans les lieux de
rencontre et parfois même dans
l'intimité de leur logie suite à une
dénonciation permettant la constitution
de fichiers d'inverti par la police
nationale et une application zéée du
droit par les juges puisque jusqu'en
93 % des condamnations liées à ces
infractions se solderont à des peines
d'emprisonnement c'est en 1977 à
l'occasion du médiatique procès du
manatan accompagné de la mobilisation
d'intellectuels comme Michel fouot et
Marguerite Duras que le législateur
envisage enfin de remettre en cause ses
dispositions uniques de notre arsenal
pénal en parlant du l'affaire du manatan
qu'il me soit permis de saluer le
courage et la ténacité d'une des
victimes de cette triste affaire le
liyonnais Michel chomara âgé de 75 ans
qui témoigne inlassablement pour lui et
pour ses compagnons d'infortune dès
1978 le Sénat ici à l'initiative de
notre regretté collègue Henry kayavé
sénateur du Lot auogaron proposa
l'abrogation de ces deux délits
d'homosexualité souhaitant tenir compte
de l'évolution des mœurs et des esprits
dans dans la société éclairé par les
arguments du sénateur kayavé la haute
assemblée de l'époque le suivit et vota
sa proposition de loi reprise par le
député maire notre regretté collègue
Michel crpau à l'Assemblée nationale
cette proposition de loi se heurtera à
l'hostilité de la majorité des députés
il faudra attendre 1980 et l'action
volontariste de Monique Peltier
secrétaire d'État de raymondb pour que
ça soit abrogé le caractère aggravant
l'homosexualité dans le cadre d'un
outrage à la pudeur la gauche arrivée au
pouvoir amnistia dès 1981 les personnes
condamnées pour homosexualité enfin le 4
août 1982 à l'initiative du ministre
Robert badenter du député du Territoire
de Belfort Raymond Forni de la
rapporteur Giselle Alimi et avec le
concours de notre ancien collègue
sénateur de hotson Jean-Pierre Michel la
majorité sexuelle discriminante héritée
de Vichy sera abrogé le sociologue
régist schlagden hofen estime entre
50000 et 60000 personnes ont été
condamnées pour homosexualité entre 45
et 82 en vertu de ces deux incrimination
ces travaux sont corroborés par de
nombreux universitaires Antoine hiidier
Sébastien landriux romain Jaouen Chérine
bzic et Marc bonenqui peu de ces
condamnés sont encore en vie à l'heure
où je vous parle quelques centaines au
mieux pour toutes les personnes
condamnées le prix a payé fut lourd si
les faits réprimés étaient assortis
d'amende ou de courtes peine de prison
ces condamn même légère constituai des
tâches indélébiles pour les personnes
concernées ces sanctions pénales
allaient de paire avec le probre social
l'ostracisation le rejet des condamnés
par leur famille elles entraînent
également bien souvent leur licenciement
ou la ruine de leur carrière
professionnelle ces pertes sociales
morales et financières ne sauraient être
évalué ces peines infamantes ont marqué
à vie des existences elles firent voler
en éclat des vies et des familles mes
chers collègues VI Hugo disait le plus
lourd fardeau c'est d'exister sans vivre
beaucoup de ces hommes continuèrent à
exister mais en ayant perdu le goût de
la vie ces condamnations poussèrent au
suicide certains malheureux acculés à la
mort par une presse peu scrupuleuse qui
étalé leur identité ou publier les
photos des déventures des commerces dans
lesquels ils travaillaient aucune loi ne
sera hélas en mesure de réparer ce
préjudice mais nous pouvons tâcher de
nous y employer et c'est bien l'objet de
cette proposition de loi celle-ci entend
dans son article 1 reconnaître la
responsabilité de la France dans les
répressions subies il a semblé que le
rapporteur souscrivait à l'objectif de
cette article souhaitant toutefois faire
débuter la reconnaissance à 1945
estimant que la République française
n'avait pas à être tenue comptable des
agissement de régime de Vichy j'ai du
mal nous avons du mal à partager son
raisonnement juridique puisque la
République a hélas repris à son compte
et conserver la loi adoptée sous le
régime de Pétin nous avons du mal à
partager son raisonnement politique
puisque le jour de la libération de
Paris le 25 août 44 à l'Hôtel de Ville
pressé par George Bidau de proclamer la
République le Général de Gaulle avait
répondu la République n'a jamais cessé
plus récemment le 16 juillet
1995 abandonnant toutes les
circonvolutions de ses prédécesseurs à
l'Élysée et même de certains de ses
compagnons du RPR le regretté Jacques
Chirac président de la République
prononça ce discours historique
fondateur reconnaissant la respons ilité
de la France dans la persécution des
Juifs pendant l'occupation le second
article de la proposition de loi propose
de réprimer la négation et la
contestation la déportation pour motif
d'homosexualité le trème article propose
un dédommagement pour les victimes
condamné je vous souhaite ici rappeler
que cette indemnisation ne concernerait
que quelques centaines de personnes mes
chers collègues je forme le vœu que sur
un tel sujet l'esprit de concorde guide
vos votes il y a des lois qui ne
souffrent ni la controverse ni la
polémique j'ai le sentiment que celle-ci
en fait partie plus qu'un symbole son
adoption permettra peut-être de refermer
les PL des personnes condamné non pas
pour ce qu'elle faisaent mais pour ce
qu'elles étaient inquiéter et condamner
quelqu'un pour son intimité pour son
identité s porter atteinte à sa dignité
réparer ses injustices penser ses
blessures apaiser la mémoire de ceux qui
ont pâti et qui sont morts c'est faire
preuve de notre humanité je conclurai en
citant Alphonse de la Martine qui disait
je suis de la couleur de C qu'on
persécute alors mes chers collègues
soyons tous et toutes comme la Martine
de la couleur de ceux qu'on persécute
de la religion de ceux qu'on opprime
soyons tous et toutes comme la Martine
de l'orientation sexuelle de ceux que la
France a condamné je vous remercie merci
chers
collègues la parole est à présent à
Monsieur Francis spinner rapporteur de
la commission des lois pour 10
minutes
monsieur le
Président Monsieur le président monsieur
le garde des saau mesdames Messieurs mes
chers
collègues le Sénat doit examiner une
loi qui dans son fondement ne peut que
recueillir évidemment que l'assentiment
de toute cette
assemblée mais en même temps le Sénat
est
tenu de faire des lois et les lois
s'appuient sur le
droit la proposition qui vous est faite
pêche sur de nombreux plan le premier
puisque vous l'avez abordé et je me
réjouis de voir combien Jacques Chirac
est populaire surtout depuis qu'il est
mort sur les bands de la gauche et que
vous le citez à tout moment la question
de la période je vous fait observer
d'abord que même ceux qui ont travaillé
distingue la période de 42 45 de la
période
4582 et d'ailleurs vous-même dans votre
proposition de loi vous le faites
puisque lors que vous parlez du déit de
négationnisme évidemment vous ne faites
pas courir le délit de négationniste
pour les faits de 45 à 82 et donc à la
fois pour une question de morale
politique je vois mal comment la
République pourrait endosser la
responsabilité des crimes de Vichi la
période 42 45 est une période qui
au-delà du cadre législatif est une
période effectivement de répression
politique de l'homosexualité d'une
manière idéologique et organisée et
voilà pourquoi j'ai fait cette
séparation et que la Commission des loi
a décidé d'adopter dans l'article 1er le
fait que les choses partent depuis
1945 le deuxème aspect de votre loi
c'est la réparation
financière là aussi vous avez cité et
c'est vrai et l'audition d'Arian chemin
était très inclérente de ce point de vu
tous les drames qui sont nés de cette
loi mais comme vous l'avez dit ce n'est
pas tellement l'application de la loi
mais le regard de la société qui a causé
ce dommage ce n'est pas parce que le
juge a condamné c'est parce que la
société française dans toute sa
composante était à l'époque
homophobe je me souviens que la moitié
des psychiatres venz vous expliquer il y
a 50 ans que l'homosexualité é étaé
inscrite par les maladies mentales je me
souviens pardonnez-moi c'est le
privilège de l'âge une émission qui
s'appelait les Dossiers de l'écran où on
disait ce soir nous allons parler d'une
maladie mentale l'homosexualité donc le
regard qu'a posé la société on peut par
anachronisme dire c'était très mal il y
a 50 ans mais ce n'est pas la loi qui en
a été la première responsable de ce
préjudice réel parce que le nombre de
drames de gens qui ont été exclus qui
ont dû changer de métier qui ont dû
changer de
ville ces drames ont été effectivement
affreux et ont causé des suicides et un
certain nombre de drames mais ça n'est
pas la faute je suis désolé de le dire
de la République c'est une
responsabilité collective de toute la
société et le Sénat n'a pas pour rôle de
venir juger la société avec ses préjugés
50 ans après nous allons nous en ten au
droit or sur le plan du droit il est
indiscutable que cette loi était
discriminatoire pour que tout le monde
comprennent ce qui était toléré entre
personnes
hétérosexuelles devenait un délit à
partir du moment il y avait lieu entre
personnes homosexuelles la même
situation ne produisant pas la même les
mêmes effets juridiques c'est le la
discrimination indiscutable et de de
cette discrimination là oui la
République a commis une faute et cette
faute est indiscutable et patente sur la
réparation toujours je vous ferai
observer que à partir du moment où nous
sommes sur le délit de
82 les articles que vous avez visé ces
articles qui sont des articles de
matière délictuell des condamnations
prononcées pour des délits la loi
d'amnistie a effacé sur le plan pénal
l'existence même de ces condamnations et
il y a des règles de prescription et que
vous ne pouvez pas 40 ans après sauf à
créer un dangereux précédent venir dire
que la prescription n'existe pas et que
donc il peut y avoir matière à
réparation mais madame de la Conterie
vous êtes une très brillante juriste
tout le monde le sait vous démontrerez
le contraire je n'en doute pas mais si
vous arrivez à me citer des exemples de
prescription plus de quantenir si vous
faites allusion à la loi mémorielle sur
les archis ça n'a strictement rien à
voir relisez la loi et vous verrez que
ce qui est réparation ce sont les
conditions indignes et l'effet d'une
politique qui est assumée par l'État ça
n'a rien à voir avec le sujet qui nous
préoccupe voilà pourquoi nous avons
estimé la commission des lois estimé
qu'il fallait effectivement ne pas
retenir le principe des réparations trè
point c'est le problème du
négationisme deux raisons pour
lesquelles la Commission ne peut pas
vous suivre la première c'est une
conception philosophique des droits de
l'homme les droits de l'homme sont
indivisibles les droits de l'homme sont
universels et à partir de ce moment-là
nous considérons que la loi le procès de
nurberg a montré que la déportation la
négation de la déportation dans son
ensemble que cela concerne les Juifs les
communistes les résistants les tiganes
les homosexuels constituaiit le crime
contre l'humanité et que donc la
négation de ce fait entre dans le cadre
de la loi qui est consacré par l'article
24 de la loi de 80 hein sur la presse et
qu'il n'y a donc pas la nécessité de
créer une infraction nouvelle qui n'est
ni légitime sur le plan de
l'indivisibilité et l'universalité des
droits de l'homme et sur le plan
juridique compenu ce que prévoit déjà le
statut de nurberg j'ajouterai d'ailleurs
que ce qui va plutôt dans le sens de
cette position c'est qu'un certain
nombre d'association luttant contre
l'homophobie ont engagé des procédures
sur le fondement de la loi de 81 et que
évidemment si on vous suivait ce serait
la preuve que ça ne rentre pas dans le
cadre de la loi de 81 et ce serait la
relaxe que ces associations poursuivent
il s'agit pas de faire plaisir à ces
associations il s'agit tout simplement
d'examiner le droit et donc voilà
pourquoi nous avons été partisans de
faire un article unique qui a été soumis
et qui reconnaît effectivement que la
République a pratiqué une politique
discriminatoire de 45 à
82 nous sommes dans le symbole et le
symbole est important il est important
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui encore
des gamins de 18 ans sont chassés de
chez eux lorsque leurs parents
découvrent leur homosexualité et il est
important que le Sénat affirme que les
lois discriminatoires contre les
homosexuels sont des lois qui sont
contraires à l'idée de ce que nous avons
de la République de la fraternité et de
la condition humaine sur ce plan-là nous
sommes d'accord mais le Sénat ne peut
pas faire plus c'est un travail
d'éducation de toute la société c'est un
travail de chacun c'est un travail dans
les familles c'est un travail dans
l'éducation ce n'est pas la loi
malheureusement qui va régler tous les
problèmes de l'homophobie mais en en
approuvant
symboliquement que la République en
créant une discrimination c'est mal
conduit je pense que c'est une aide qui
est apportée à ceux qui mènent ce combat
qui est un un combat légitime voilà
pourquoi j'aurais souhaité un consensus
dernier point que je voudrais aborder et
je suis sûr monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le l'auteur de la proposition
de loi que vous aurez l'honnêteté
intellectuelle de dire que c'est vrai
nous n'avons pas refusé et j'étais très
choqué de le lire un certain nombre
d'auditions nous avons dû agir dans un
temps très court qui n'est pas du fait
ni de la commission ni du rapporteur ce
que nous n'avons pas pu entendre nous
leur avons demandé des contributions
écrites et ils nous les ont fournis et
dire que nous avons refusé ou que nous
avons bâlé le sujet est assez scandaleux
et je suis sûr que vous aurez raison de
rectifier tout cela mais ces critiques
sont intéressantes parce qu'elles
montrent qu'en réalité vous englobez un
problème qui couvre des périodes
différentes des situations différentes
et que je pense que le travail reste à
faire et que il serait souhaitable
effectivement que l'autorité publique
prenne un certain nombre de décisions
pour missionner des universitaires les
encourager les aider dans leurs travaux
pour avoir une réalité de ce qui s'est
passé car lorsque nous avons interrogé
la direction des affaires criminelles et
des grâces nous avons été dans
l'impossibilité et d'une certaine
manière c'est heureux ça prouve qu'il y
a pas de fichier à la Chancellerie des
gens condamnés pour homosexualité ce qui
est plutôt heureux mais nous avons
beaucoup de travail à faire et le
chercheur qui est le plus actif en la ti
reconnaît toute la difficulté de sa
tâche pour regarder PV par PV donc je
pense que nous pouvons arriver à une
bonne loi de consensus qui réaffirme un
principe oui la République a fauté mais
vous ne pouvez pas aller au-delà je vous
remercie merci chers collègu la parole
est à présent à monsieur Éric DUP pont
Moretti garde des saau ministre de la
Justice
bonsoir monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Président Monsieur
le Président de la commission des lois
monsieur le sénateur Bourgi monsieur le
rapporteur spiner mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs nous nous retrouvons
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de la niche
socialiste pour débattre d'un sujet de
grande
importance et sans aucun doute trop
longtemps oublié et je veux le dire
d'emblé monsieur le
sénateur votre proposition de loi a
indubitablement beaucoup de
sens et je veux d'ailleurs vous en
remercier
chaleureusement en vous écoutant tout à
l'heure je me disais mais on a vraiment
du mal à imaginer
aujourd'hui même si tout n'est pas
parfait à quel point les homosexuels ont
été
maltraité
malmené
méprisé c'est simple aujourd'hui au fond
nous sommes réunis pour dire que la
République n'est jamais aussi
grande que lorsqu'elle sait reconnaître
ses erreurs et ici ses fautes car oui
votre texte monsieur le sénateur Bourgie
a pour objet la reconnaissance par la
République française de la politique de
discrimination mise en œuvre pendant
près de 40 ans à l'encontre des
personnes xuel et condamné à raison de
leur orientation sexuelle réelle ou
présumé si cette politique passée de
discrimination fait aujourd'hui honte à
notre République je tiens toutefois à
rappeler qu'il n'en a pas toujours été
ainsi alors que les relations
homosexuelles étaient incriminé durant
l'Ancien Régime elles ont été
décriminalisé en 1791 au lendemain de la
révolution de sorte que pendant plus
d'un siècle et demi aucune incrimination
de l'homosexualité n'était en vigueur
dans notre pays ce faisant notre pays
était fort de cette législation l'un des
plus progressistes mais tout cela a été
balayé avec l'instauration du régime de
Vichi car c'est bien Vichi qui aura
raison de cet acquis puisque la loi du 6
août 19 142 modifiant l'article 334 du
code pénal punira d'un emprisonnement de
6 mois à 3 ans quiconque aura commis un
ou plusieurs actes impudiques ou contre
nature avec un mineur de son sexe âgé de
moins de 21
ans comme vous le rappelez monsieur le
sénateur Bourgis ces évolutions
législatives ont bouleversé et parfois
détruit la vie des homosexuels de
l'époque en donnant une base légale à ce
qui fut une véritable
répression non pas de ce qu'elle faisait
mais de ce qu'ells étaient cela bien sûr
nous ne l'acceptons plus et aujourd'hui
non seulement nous le reconnaissons mais
d'ù nous le dénonçons et nous pouvons le
dénoncer grâce à votre loi au fond vous
substiuez à une loi de haine une loi
d'unité de reconnaissance de mémoire j'y
suis favorable il m'est impossible de ne
pas rappeler qu'il fallut pour mettre un
terme à cette répression pénale attendre
Robert Badinter sa majorité socialiste
d'Alor et la loi du 4 août
1982 enfin devrais-je dire pour voir
cette disposition abroger et mettre
ainsi un terme à 40 années de
pénalisation de
l'homosexualité quand on vous parle de
bas d'interre tout tout le monde pense à
l'abolliition de la peine de mort qui
est en soit déjà une œuvre presque
complète pour un garde des saau un de
mes très anciens prédécesseur m'avait
confessé après ma prise de fonction la
difficulté qui fut la sienne de passer
au ministère de la justice après
l'illustre
Badinter et il ajoutait mi résigné mi
philosophe que voulez-vous Eric on
abolit la peine de mort qu'une seule
fois heureusement pour lui il avait
oublié cette autre œuvre majeure que fut
la dépénalisation de
l'homosexualité 40 ans plus tard il est
plus que temps de reconnaître sur le
plan mémoriel que les condamnations
prononcées l'ont été sur le fondement de
lois
erronées en effet comme vous le savez
chaque condamnation ou mise en cause
portant sur une infraction liée à
l'homosexualité a eu des conséquences
sociales lourdes et parfois est souvent
dévastatrice pour la personne qui en a
fait l'objet jusqu'au bannissement de la
de la sphère familiale ou professionnel
si mon ministère ne dispose pas de
chiffres quant au nombre de ces
condamnations et on en est tous très
heureux s'agissant d'infraction
aujourd'hui abrogé divers travaux de
recherche menés sur le sujet estime que
plus de 10000 personnes ont été condamné
entre
1945 et
1982 avec pour plus de 90 % d'entre
elles une condamnation à une peine
d'emprisonnement ferme ces chiffres
évidemment nous interpellent et nous
obligent à œuvrer ensemble à reconnaître
clairement et sans aucune ambiguité la
mise en œuvre de cette législation
déshonorante la proposition de loi qui
vous est aujourd'hui présentée poursuit
cette objectif et doit à ce titre
retenir toute notre attention et je le
dis toute notre bienveillance
allons maintenant dans les détails de
ces
dispositions l'article 1er de cette
proposition prévoit ainsi de reconnaître
la responsabilité de la République
Française pour la politique de
discrimination mise en œuvre à
l'encontre des homosexuels ou présumer
tel et condamné sur la base d'infraction
aujourd'hui abrogé j'y suis favorable
sur le principe et je sais que le
rapporteur spiner apportera par endement
certaines précisions
intéressantes cette écriture de
compromis aura surtout l'avantage de
permettre sous toute réserve bien sûr
l'adoption par le Sénat d'un texte
important pour l'apaisement de notre
société je crois que dans le contexte
actuel il serait vraiment dommage de
s'en priver l'article 2 créer un nouvel
article dans la loi du 29 juillet
1881 sur la liberté de la presse afin de
réprimer le fait de contester nier
minorer ou banaliser l'existence de
déportation de personnes en raison de
leur homosexualité depuis la France et
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale je
tiens à rappeler devant vous qu'il ne
fait aucun doute j'insiste aucun doute
que les personnes homosexuelles ont bien
été déporté pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et qu'il s'agit là de crime
évidemment atrocce toutefois toutefois
j'aiimis une réserve quant à la
constitutionnalité de cette nouvelle
infraction en effet le Conseil
constitutionnel a déjà jugé que le
législateur ne pouvait créer
d'incrimination réprimant pénalement la
contestation d'une vérité historique
lorsqu'elle était établie par la loi en
raison de l'atteinte porté à la liberté
d'expression une reconnaissance
judiciaire préalable et nécessaire ce
qui n'est en l'état pas le cas l'article
3 ouvre au bénéfice des personnes
condamnées en application des
infractions visées à l'article 1er une
allocation forfaitaire de 10000 € ainsi
qu'une allocation variable en fonction
du nombre de jours de privation de
liberté fixé à 150 € par jour elle
prévoit également le remboursement du
montant de l'amende dont les personnes
reconnues coupable se sont acquittés en
application de leur condamnation
toutefois il s'agit là d'une mesure
d'indemnisation nécessitant bien sûr
d'apporter la preuve d'une condamnation
ancienne difficile à rapportter tant
dans son principe le jugement que dans
sa mise à exécution à savoir
l'application de la peine en question sa
mise en pratique apparaît donc
extrêmement extrêmement complexe
l'article 4 et je termine institue
auprès de la première ministre une
commission nationale indépendante de
reconnaissance de réparation des
préjudices subis par les personnes
condamnées chargé de statuer sur les
demandes d'indemnisation présenté ces
dispositions semblent relever plutôt du
domaine réglementaire et poser là encore
des difficultés probatoires liées bien
sûr à l'ancienneté des faits pouvant
donner à indemnisation vous l'aurez
compris au regard des différentes
réserves énoncées précédemment sur les
articles 2 3 et 4 le gouvernement s'en
remettra à la sagesse du Sénat mesdames
messieurs les sénateurs le Gouvernement
est favorable au principe de cette
proposition de loi qui viendra
reconnaître la mise en œuvre pendant 40
ans d'une politique de discrimination et
de répression pénale qui n'aurait jamais
dû exister s'il est toujours complexe de
regarder les lois d'hier avec les
lunettes d'aujourd'hui il en va ici des
principes fondamentaux non négociables
de notre République celui de la liberté
celui de l'égalité et bien sûr et bien
sûr celui de la fraternité c'est
pourquoi il est impératif de reconnaître
les aements du passé mais aussi leurs
terribles conséquences pour
plusieurs génération de nos compatriotes
reconnaître une erreur ça n'est à
l'évidence pas un une marque de
faiblesse loin de là c'est dire que nos
principes fondamentaux valent plus que
notre orgueil car l'orgueil d'être
français c'est aussi d'en assumer toute
notre
histoire toute l'histoire de notre pays
et dire lorsque l'on a fait fausse route
pour montrer aux générations
futures que notre République les
principes universels qui la soutendent
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
triompent toujours la France a connu ses
lumières et prise de liberté et
d'égalité elle fut le premier pays au
monde à supprimer les infractions
réprimant l'homosexualité en 1791 elle a
aussi ses par d'ombre la loi pénalisant
l'homosexualité prise sous le régime de
Vichy est malheureusement confirmée à la
Libération a conduit à la condamnation
de plusieurs milliers de personnes
jusqu'aux lois d'amnistie en 1981 puis
d'abrogation en 82 la proposition de loi
portée par notre collègue husin Bourgi
nous permet de tourner enfin ces pages
sombres de notre histoire nationale et
reconnaître les erreurs commises par nos
prédécesseurs et en conséquence les
réparer elle permettrait à notre pays de
s'inscrire dans le mouvement des nations
et a des gens emprunter cette voix
courageuse je pense à l'Allemagne dont
le trisème rche a fait des milliers de
victimes condamnées pour l'homosexualité
à l'Espagne dont le régime franquiste
s'est engagé dans la lutte contre
l'homosexualisme ou encore au Canada et
en tous trois instaurer des réparations
financières à l'instar de ce que propose
ce texte ayant l'audace de suivre suivre
ces exemples à l'heure où partout dans
le monde les droits sociaux les plus
élémentaires sont remis en cause en
décembre 1981 au côté de Robert batire
Giselle à liimi se demander comment avec
le recul les députés français
c'est-à-dire par définition des hommes
et des femmes qui devraient avoir
l'intelligence de nos libertés
fondamentales puisqu'ils sont chargés de
les défendre ont pu légiférer pour
réprimer l'homosexualité je souhaite
aujourd'hui que nous fassions preuve de
cette intelligence que nous tendions la
main à ceux qui ont été injustement
marginalisés et les
et laisé pardon le Sénat peut envoyer
aujourd'hui un message de tolérance et
de respect à notre société que je crois
en quête d'apaisement c'est la raison
pour laquelle je voterai sans réserve en
faveur de cette proposition de loi et
vous invite à faire de même merci la
parole est à présent au président Pierre
ououias merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mais mes chers
collègues la proposition de loi porté
sur une période allant de 1942 à 1982
monsieur le rapporteur vous nous
proposez de réduire cette période en
sortant Vichy de son champ d'application
et je vous cite vous considérez que le
régime de Vichy ne paraît pas pouvoir
être valablement pris en compte or chers
collègues je me permets de vous signaler
que le Parlement a voté à l'unanimité la
loi du 23 juillet 2023 qui porte
reconnaissance d'espoliation antisémite
commise par l'état français du 10
juillet 1940 au 24 août 1944
il ne peut pas y avoir chers collègues
de réparation des crimes commis par
Vichy sans reconnaissance des lois de
Vichy il serait totalement
incompréhensible que le Parlement
reconnaisse l'espoliation antisémite qui
font l'objet de restitution et
d'indemnisation et pas les persécutions
commises par le même régime contre les
homosexuels certes chers collègues
vichis n'était pas la République mais
c'était un régime à la tête duquel le
maréchal Pétin a obtenu les pleins
pouvoirs et à l'époque 569
parlementaires avaient voté pour et 80
avaient voté contre merci à ces 80 qui
avait voté contre merci monsieur le
Président merci monsieur
Lurel merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre je voudrais sans
hésiter ce texte notre collègue husin
Bourgin mais j'aimerais réagir à ce qu'a
dit monsieur le ministre que il faudrait
au préalable qu'il y ait une
condamnation par une un tribunal ou une
instance internationale et en général on
évoque
nurber on m'a opposé la même chose
lorsqu'on a voulu reconnaître la
négation du génocide arménien on nous a
opposé également la même chose lorsqu'on
a voulu donner une prescription
normative à la loi mémorielle
tobira il est possible et j'ai entendu
une de nos collègues de le dire c'est
une jurisprudence de la Cour de
cassation qui empêche de reconnaître un
délice spécifique notamment en raison de
l'orientation sexuelle donc la ce que
notre rapporteur à exposé en disant
qu'il a presqueun impossibilité
juridique imposée par une jurisprudence
absolument réactionnaire de la Cour de
cassation il est possible de créer ce
délit spécifique lorsque il y
a les injustices qui ont été commises en
raison de l'orientation sexuelle c'est
un bon
sexe merci Madame
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues l'homophobie
tue et le silence aussi la pénalisation
de l'homosexualité en France a tué y
compris après son abrogation oui la
République que ce soit celle de Vichy
jusqu'à la 5e doit le reconnaître et
réparer le préjudice causé par ces lois
parce que sinon sinon cela ce cela ne
s'arrête arrêtera pas les morts ne
s'arrêteront pas juin 92 plus de 10 ans
déjà après les première détection de ce
qui sera appelé le cancer gai pour la
première fois j'aiécris dans le journal
du sida c'était le numéro 40 page 51 du
numéro une intervention du magistrat Yve
jouau président du fond d'indemnisation
des hémophiles et des transfusés
contaminé par le VIH déjà la question de
l'indemnisation est posée page 5
j'écrivais inutile de cacher les toxicos
et les homos 82 1 an après que le
premier article de presse relatif au
sida paraît dans le New York Times la
France dépénalise l'homosexualité trop
tard la Stig la stigmatisation perdure
et l'épidémie s'installe double
condamnation condamné pour homosexualité
condamné à mort par une épidémie que
l'homophobie d'État n'a pas voulu
reconnaître et combattre à temps les
communautés
LGBTQI plus savent ce que le VIH leur a
pris et nous savons ce que nous devons à
la santé communautaire pour rétablir la
justice face au préjudicees créés par
ces lois de criminalisation et de
discrimination de Cell qui de facto ont
conduit à des peines de mort massives je
voterai évidemment en faveur de cet
article et de cette proposition après
cette première pierre contre les
discriminations poursuivons cette
politique mémorielle mais aussi de
réparation sans purge de l'histoire et
souvenons-nous de ce que nous devons y
compris aux combattantes et aux
combattants du sida je vous remercie
merci Monsieur
Paumier monsieur le président monsieur
le garde des saau mes chers collègues je
voudrais souligner que les résistants
homosexuels n'ont guère été honorés par
la nation et qu'il y a matière ce soir à
le rendre aussi justice le rapporteur a
rappelé dans son propos le nom de Jean
desbord qui illustre ce manquement
l'écrivain Jean desbord un tempant
compagnon de Jean cocto est entré dans
la Résistance sous le nom de Duroc il
est mort sous la torture des nazis dans
la nuit du 5 auou 6 juillet 1944 à 38
ans son nom d'écrivain figure certes au
Panthéon parmi ceux des écrivains morts
pour la France mais rien pour le
résistant Jean desborde qu'il a été et
qui en gardant le silence sous la
torture a protégé ses compagnons et
sauvé une partie de son réseau
francopolon
F2 Daniel Cordier résistant et
secrétaire de Jean Moulin a d'ailleurs
mis très longtemps avant de révéler son
homosexualité dans son autobiographie la
haine à l'égard de l'homosexualité était
terrible disait-il alors ce texte ce
soir est important il est symbolique
notre responsabilité aussi pour rendre
justice à ces résistants homosexuels à
travers un texte de réparation et
d'apaisement
merci merci cher chers
collègues à l'article 1er je suis saisi
d'un amendement et d'un
sous-amendement je amendement de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur
amendement numéro
1 monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Président Mesdames Messieurs chers
collègues je vais donc proposer
l'amendement suivant la République
française reconnaît sa responsabilité du
fait de l'application des dispositions
pénales suivantes à compter du 8 février
45 qui ont constitué une discrimination
fondée sur l'orientation
sexuelle suit la liste des infractions
visées elle reconnaît que ces
dispositions ont été source de
souffrance et de traumatisme pour les
personnes condamnées de manière
discriminatoire sur leurs
fondement
merci monsieur monsieur Bourgi pour la
présentation du sous-amendement numéro
3 monsieur le Président mes chers
collègues vous l'avez compris ma
préférence ne va pas à cet amendement à
cette mouture là mais si c'est celle-ci
qui devait être retenue je propose un
sous-amendement qui associe à la mouture
proposée par notre collègue rapporteur
la réparation je m'adresse à tous les
juristes et ils sont un certain nombre
ici je m'adresse aux pénalistes et il y
en a quelquesuns ici en droit français
lorsqu'on va devant le tribunal
lorsqu'on va devant les cours c'est pour
faire établir et reconnaître la
culpabilité de quelqu'un dès lors que la
culpabilité a été
retenue pour être cohérent pour être
logique il faut que le tort qui a été
infligé à quelqu'un que je préjudice qui
a été infligé au plaignant soit
indemnisé j'entends les difficultés que
cela peut représenter pour trouver les
victimes mais justement la mouture que
je propose c'est que que ce soit les
victimes qui se manifestent comme pour
l'archi ni plus ni moins le rapporteur a
soulevé un certain nombre d'objections
d'ordre juridique il se trouve que
d'éminents juristes que j'ai consulté
des spécialistes en matière de droit
pénal et y compris des spécialistes de
la haute assemblée qui m'ont assisté
dans la rédaction de cette proposition
de loi ne partage pas son point de vue
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle je
persiste et signe une reconnaissance
sans réparation on aurait franchi que la
moitié du chemin et dans quelques années
on devrait revenir pour dire finalement
on va prévoir une réparation qui ne
serait jamais appliqué c'est typiquement
le genre de loi qu'on sait voter que les
parlementaires savent voter et qui ont
pour seul but de donner bonne conscience
au parlementaires parce que les
principaux concernés ne sont plus en vie
donc je vous propose ce sousamendement
qui prévoit la réparation pour que nous
soyons cohérents jusqu'au bout
reconnaissance et
réparation merci chers collègu avis de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur
sous ce sousamendement numéro 3
en général je ne réponds jamais aux
lettres anonyme donc lorsque vous me
citez d'éminents juristes je suis sûr
que ils pourront se manifester
clairement indiquer leur nom et les
arguments maintenant quand vous allez
devant un tribunal il se trouve qu'il y
a des règles la première c'est la
prescription civile ça existe et donc
que la prescription est acquise vous
trouverez toujours des juristes et s'ils
veulent se manifester auprès de moi
ouvertement je serai ravi de leur
répondre et je dis la prescription ça
existe la deuxième chose plus gravement
c'est que le préjudice résulte de quoi
il résulte à la fois de la loi pénale
mais c'est-à-dire que vous demandez à la
République d'indemniser l'application
par des juges d'une loi qui est une
mauvaise loi mais qui é appliqué par des
juges la nature du préjudice la vraie
gravité du préjudice qui découle de
cette loi elle est le fait de la société
et donc elle ne résulte pas de la loi
directement donc ça poserait aussi
d'autres problèmes voilà pourquoi je je
pense que cette réparation aujourd'hui
n'a pas de sens la réparation elle est
symbolique elle est morale je me réjouis
je me réjouis de votre proposition de
loi vous avez tiré de l'oubli ces
manquements de la République mais je
pense que la loi mémorielle
suffit merci monsieur le rapporteur avis
du gouvernement que l' viis est
défavorable évidemment avis du
gouvernement sur l'amendement et le
sous-amendement monsieur le ministre
merci merci monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Rapporteur comme je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure sont des avis de sagesse que le
gouvernement veut exprimer l'important
c'est un
texte le gouvernement n'entend pas
entrer dans dans dans dans dans dans les
dissensions et encore le mot est mal
choisi à l'évidence
euh voilà avite de sagesse et je
n'exprimerai c'est assez rare que le
gouvernement ne s'exprime qu'ainsi je
n'exprimerai que des avis de sagesse
pardon non monsieur darmana n'a rien à
voir làdedans moi c'est du porti
voilà ah oui il a fait ça la semaine
dernière je savais pas merci monsieur le
ministre je suis saisi de plusieurs
demandes de parole à commencé par Madame
Rossignol merci monsieur le Président
j'avoue que l'amendement présenté par le
rapporteur
pose beaucoup de problèmes son intention
j'imagine est de protéger la République
qui pourrait être par une lecture rapide
assimilé à la période de Vichi et vous
voulez protéger la République mais pour
se faire en fait vous effacez ce qu'on
subit les personnes homosexuelles en
France pendant la période de Vichy vous
effacez ce qu' a très bien évoqué il y a
un instant votre collègue pommier notre
collègue pommier qui eux ne seront pas
visés par ce texte donc d'une main vous
PRG République mais je reviendrai pas
sur les propos du président Chirac moi
je sa pas je ne cite pas Jacques Chirac
continuellement mais enfin je cite le
président de la République parce que il
a fait ce jour-là dans ce propos un acte
important pour la déportation des Juifs
nous avons l'occasion de faire le même
et puis aussi désagréable que ce soit il
y a des politiques qui ont connu une
grande continuité entre Vichi et la 4e
République je vais vous en citer une la
politique de criminalisation et de
poursuite des femmes qui avortaient
cette politique a conduit souvichi à
aller jusqu'à la peine de mort mais elle
ne s'est pas arrêté la peine de mort a
été supprimée mais elle ne s'est pas
arrêté avec la 4e République elle s'est
même intensifié puisque'à partir de 46
les femmes qui recouraient à des
avortement étit poursuivi et voire même
toutes les structures mises en place
sous Vichi pour pour les identifier ont
été renforcé donc c'est désagréable à
entendre mais des politiques moralistes
celles qui visent à pénaliser les droits
sexuels et reproductifs ceux des femmes
comme ceux des homosexuels ont connu une
continuité par ailleurs le texte de
notre collègue ne parle pas de
responsabilité c'est vous qui qui
introduisez la notion de responsabilité
le texte de notre collègue dit la
République français reconnais reconnaît
et regrette elle ne dit pas qu'elle est
responsable mais vous voulant dire
qu'elle est responsable vous excluez les
homosexuels qui ont été déportés qui ont
sou souffert sous Vichi merci madame de
La
Gonterie merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers
collègues l'amendement que propose le
rapporteur n'a qu'une vocation c'est
d'exclure la période du Vichy ça a été
euh rappelé par notre collègue et par
Pierre ououlias quel était le le
contresens alors sans doute pour faire
un bon mot le rapporteur dit ah mais la
gauche cite Jacques shirac mais moi je
ne cite pas Jaques Chirac je cite le
président de la République et quand le
16 juillet 95 il dit reconnaître les
fautes du passé c'est défendre une idée
de l'homme de sa liberté de sa dignité
lorsqu'il dit cette phrase historique
oui la folie criminelle de l'occupant a
été second les Français second par
l'état français lorsquil dit reconnaître
les fautes du passé les fautes commises
par l'État ne rien occulter des hor
sombr de notre histoire c'est tout
simplement défendre une idée de l'homme
de sa liberté de sa dignité c'est lutter
contre les forces obscures sans cesse à
l'uvre c'est cela que nous vous
demandons aujourd'hui nous vous
demandons pas de d'avaliser de quelque
manière que ce soit ce qui s passé sous
Vichi nous demandons que nous le
prenions en compte et donc il y a une
curiosité tout de même mais j'ai vu que
vous aviez prudemment demandé un scrutin
public ainsi nous pourrons chacun
prendre des responsabilités il y a quand
même une curiosité à vouloir effacer de
notre mémoire collective et de notre
responsabilité collective cette période
de l'histoire et c'est pour cela que je
citais le président de la
République
merci président
zouias merci monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mais mes chers
collègues monsieur le rapporteur vous
vous m'avez pas répondu sur le parallèle
que je fais entre votre votre
proposition d'amendement et la loi du du
23 juillet 2023 chers collègues cette
loi du 23 juillet 2023 nous l'avons voté
ensemble et contre l'AVE du gouvernement
le gouvernement à cette époque là
souhaitait confondre la responsabilité
de Vichy et la responsabilité du Reich
allemand et c'est dans cet hémicycle et
je me souviens très bien de mon collègue
Max Brisson et de sa défense et de
Monsieur carucci et de sa défense
extrêmement forte pour que le Parlement
enfin reconnaisse les lois de Vichy
parce qu'elles sont pas distinctes de ce
qui s'est passé après et donc là chers
collègues en votant l'amendement de
notre abanteur vous revenez vous revenez
sur un pas historique du Parlement sur
quelque chose qui a été voté à à
l'unanimité je vous demande vraiment de
faire attention parce que je pense que
en ce moment avec la montée des actes
antisémites ce que ce que vous allez
faire serait assez catastrophique merci
chers collègues
merci monsieur le rapporteur vous voulez
ajouter quelque chose
oui d'abord quand vous parlez de la
reconnaissance je rappelle quand même
que sous Vichi on a confisqué des bien
qui était encore dans les musées
nationaux et qui appartenaient encore à
l'état ce qui expliquait peut-être que
on ait pu faire ça deuxièmement vous
faites vous-même la différence dans la
proposition de loi puisque vous
distinguez la période négationniste la
pour le négationniste la période de
Vichi et la période post Vichi donc moi
venir dire que
j'fface venir dire que j'fface la
répression des homosexuels en disant
c'est la République et joubl Vichi on
peut tout entendre mais c'est faux pour
moi le problème de la répression la
déportation des homosexuels elle est
réglée par Nuremberg il y a pas à
revenir dessus c'est un crime contre
l'humanité et personne n'entend le
minoré voilà donc à partir de ce
moment-là je veux bien qu'on soit taxé
de révisionniste de refaire l'histoire
la vérité c'est que quand quand le
président de la République pardonnez-moi
ma familiarité m'a amené à l'appeler
Jacques quand le président de la
République dit ce qu'il dit il dit
l'État français les Français ont secondé
il ne dit pas la France il ne dit pas la
République parce que vifi ça n'est pas
ça ne sera jamais la
République merci Madame lincol
held merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais redire à notre rapporteur que
pendant la période de Vichy de 1942 à 45
il s'est passé de choses différentes il
s'est passé la première qui est liée à
la pénalisation de l'homosexualité sur
le fondement du code pénal des articles
si je ne m'abuse 330 331 qui a conduit à
des la nation à des amendes à des
emprisonnements c'est cela que vous
allez effacer en nous proposant de ne
retenir que la période de 45 à 82 ça
n'est pas la déportation ça c'est
l'autre élément qui s'est en effet passé
sous Vichy et pour lequel vous avez un
autre avis défavorable sur la création
du dél spécifique de négationnisme mais
là avec votre amendement c'est
l'ensemble que vous effacez que vous
ayez envie de de ne pas intégrer la
question du déli spécifique sur le
négancionisme on peut l'entendre c'est
un autre débat mais là ce que vous
effacez en même temps c'est le même
délit celui qui a conduit non pas
nécessairement à des déportations et
d'ailleurs les chiffres le montrent il y
a beaucoup moins de déportation que de
condamnation sur le le le pardon le
fondement du code pénal ce que vous
effacez ce sont les mêmes condamnations
les mêmes emprisonnement les mêmes
amendes les mêmes conséquences pour les
familles que celles qui qui auront eu
lieu après 1900
45 merci mes chers collègues j'ai été
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
sur cet amendement et ce sous-amendement
je vais mettre au voix ce d'abord le
sous-amendement avec un avis défavorable
de la commission et un avis de sagesse
du gouvernement le scrutin est ouvert le
scrutin est donc
clos résultat de ce scrutin sur le
sous-amendement numéro 3 votant
344 exprimé 321 pour 122 contre 199 ce
sous-amendement numéro 3 n'est pas
adopté toujours saisi d'une demande de
scrutin public je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement numéro 1 de la commission
monsieur le rapporteur qui a fait
l'objet d'un avis de sagesse du
gouvernement le scrutin est ouvert
résultat du scrutin votant
344 exprimé 337 pour 221 contre 116
l'amendement numéro 1 est adopté et il
vaut adoption de l'article
1er à l'article 2 je suis saisi d'une
demande de parole madame audre linceneld
c'est bon monsieur bourg
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues j'ai une
divergence majeure sur cet amendement
sur cet article avec le rapporteur et
avec ce qui a pu être dit tout à
l'heure le rapporteur a fait
systématiquement référence à
Nuremberg moi je vais faire référence à
ce qui s'est passé en France en 2012 un
député du Nord Christian vanest a évoqué
la déportation pour motif
d'homosexualité pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale en parlant de légende le
président du parti Jean-François Copé a
pris une décision courageuse dans les
heures qui suivaient en l'excluant du
parti des associations ont porté
plainte lorsque l'affaire a été jugée 2
ans plus tard en 2014 Christian vanest a
été
relaxé en 2022 à l'occasion de
l'élection
présidentielle un nouveau responsable
ble politique Éric Zemour a tenu
exactement les mêmes propos aujourd'hui
une plainte est déposée devant les
tribunaux je l'ai dit en commission des
lois je le redis ici dans l'hémicycle
nous ne pouvons pas attendre et espérer
un éventuel revirement
jurisprudentiel et je veux dire avec
beaucoup d'amitié et de respect à notre
collègue rapporteur avec lequel j'ai
particulièrement bien travaillé je
regrette qu'un certain nombre
d'associations qui font autorité en
France sur la déportation des homosexuel
pendant la Seconde Guerre mondiale
n''est pas été auditionné je pense au
Mémorial de la déportation homosexuelle
je pense aux oubliés de la mémoire et je
pense à un certain nombre d'historiens
qui aujourd'hui se sentent un peu mis à
l'écart parce que si nous avons ce débat
aujourd'hui dans cet hémicycle c'est
parce qu'il y a eu des chercheurs il y a
eu des universitaires qui ont été
délibérément mis de côté laissés à
l'écart parce que nous avons été pris
par le temps donc je le dis ici sans
esprit polémique mais j'ai entendu leur
récrimination parce que j'en ai été le
récepteur acle ils m'ont tous écrit
pensant que c'était l'auteur qui
décidait de qui il auditionnait ça n'est
pas le cas et je forme le vœux que lors
de la seconde lecture nous puissions
auditionner toutes ces personnes qui ont
des choses à nous dire voilà pour les
débats autour de cette proposition de
loi elle a été adoptée mercredi soir en
séance n'hésitez pas à en lire le résumé
sur notre site publicsenat.fr nos
journalistes he qui vous expliquent que
le texte reconnaît bien cette
discrimination mais ne met pas en place
de système de réparation ce serait trop
compliqué selon la droite sénatoriale
c'est la fin de cette émission merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi très belle suite
des programmes sur public
[Musique]
sénna